hey guys hope you won't Samuel leaves
here and on this video so much scheme of
some amazing people so we've got mr.
Steve he's a CEO of Christian vision
[Music]
Joe we got Dave here and Dave is gonna
be holding the video camera and you
recommissioned this one outside I'm
quite excited about this job at you
something it's probably one of the best
jobs you've ever given this video make
yeah yeah it's a privilege an honor so
thank you Dave's awesome this is
actually one of my pastors so great you
guys are just doing me I don't think I'm
allowed to code because I think we
better be more let's go so why don't you
just ask me some Q&A questions and I'll
start answering okay so my first
question is why on earth would I ever
bother getting involved in property
investing I've got the job I've got a
lovely house you know I'm pleased very
stable and secure like why would I
bother I guess I wouldn't say every
single person should invest a property
he brings financial freedom it brings
security so I mean what would you know
what about the hassle faster because I
understand about security Nappanee I get
that but it seems to me like yeah let me
ask you a question okay we've been on
with it away together on stuff right now
we're on a skiing trip for a week yeah
how many times have you seen me on the
phone with tenants phone email and
property problems no not Joe so where's
the hassle well the hassle somewhere is
maybe not on this mess - okay one of
those we will dress it I guess it is
hassle but if you've got a good property
manager
like sound hassles boys a property
manager okay so alright so apart from
buying your book I would say believe you
can do it believe it's possible learn
how to do it
I'm quite interested in you for lots of
different reasons thanks des right now I
mean trust me why you do what you do
yeah okay why did you get into property
investing see these are the deeper
question to the mountain I do what I do
because I want to be the best version of
myself as I can be and I believe if God
has given you an ability to do something
the right to do it support to do it not
to do it our laziness or apathy when you
can then help a lot of people and be the
best version of yourself you can be
assumed so I do because I can I do
because I enjoy the lifestyle I enjoy
the freedom and I enjoy been able to
travel help people make a difference and
change lives through life okay so tell
me about you men to know about business
they are the purpose how important is it
for anybody to have a compelling why it
gets them up in the morning great
question
I think it's I think it's fundamental if
you haven't got a reason for doing what
you do even if you win the game even if
you guys make a million pounds become
financially free then you know you're
looking forward unfulfilled whereas if
you have a reason behind it
that journey will be from the
destination will be fun so yeah so
rather than saying what would you choose
purpose or burning love happiness school
well I just think why not choose
everything one it was kind of and you
know so
leprosy but simply have to choose to
focus on running I would say purpose
the money will often be a good tool to
get to that purpose so they're not
separate as we see the two Michaels
absolutely so that is what we're really
about community love and purpose but not
afraid to make some money along the way
absolutely know if you so enjoy myself I
will try and get some better footage
when the sun is shining tomorrow have
schemed but I wanted to make sure you
got this on Monday at 7 p.m.
you
[Music]